[Aplausos]
[Música]
yo soy puertorriqueño mis padres son
puertorriqueños mis abuelos son
puertorriqueños mis bisabuelos son
puertorriqueños y a través de ellos me
enseñaron a amar esta tierra yo diría y
por muchos años colegios de turismo que
en puerto rico y en una ocasión invitan
en washington dc un congreso de expertos
y educadores de turismo y fuimos fue
bien interesante porque había gente de
toda américa latina pero les quería
comentar que imagínense aparte de la
dinámica de uno compartir con otra gente
también nos bromeamos mucho entre
nosotros pero bien dos personas que
jamás olvidaré ninguno eran
puertorriqueños eran de otros países
cada vez que mencionaba puerto rico uno
de ellos hacía así pero yo no entendía y
me acerqué o que me pregunten viste hay
que aportar y que chiquito de que bello
el por qué y lo segundo que pasaba era
otra persona de otro país que tenía la
broma con nosotros de a puerto rico
hablar siempre de lo mismo que es bueno
en belleza que bueno en deporte qué
bueno de actuación y que bueno música
tropical y ese era la broma de youtube
cada vez que mencionan puerto rico ellos
esas dos cositas nosotros
como distintos países tenían que hacer
su presentación en distintos días ellos
hicieron su presentación y comentaron
eso cuando hicieron mañana tenemos a
puerto rico uno se levantó y me hizo así
y el otro dijo van a hablar de belleza y
de cultura mire el deporte somos
buenísimo no hay duda yo entiendo que él
lo diga en belleza también el tercer
país del mundo con más reina es verdad
que hay gente que sea como centella pero
gente bonita también en los de actuación
ni se diga el país con más oscar en el
país pero con más oscar y en música
tropical también y cuando nos vamos a
presentar con ellos que empezamos a
hablar y todo bien chévere vamos a hacer
la presentación y nosotros dijimos es
cierto lo que dice a un amigo aquí que
puerto rico es muy bueno en deportes en
belleza en música tropical en actuación
pero hay otras áreas en que también lo
somos por ejemplo vamos a hacerlo por
continente en norteamérica canadá
la ópera ópera un boricua ópera somos
buena música tropical pero oiga hace más
de 40 años a canadá llega a una persona
y esa persona empieza a trabajar con la
industria de la ópera en canadá funda
las instituciones más importantes en el
canadá acerca de la ópera y hace apenas
unos años lo proclamaron uno de los diez
disparos más importantes de canadá que
pasó que es puertorriqueños de ponce se
llama guillermo silva marín y se merece
un aplauso
y ellos ya a trevor yo espera hoy este
chavo pero para lo que él me dio me
intrigó en eeuu de puebla el de justicia
somos buenos de esas cuatro cosas pero
en justicia también la corte suprema o
el tribunal supremo de eeuu no solamente
es importante en ese país es importante
a nivel mundial porque en muchas
ocasiones toman decisiones que afectan a
todo el planeta cuando fueron a escoger
la primera la primera persona que en ese
tribunal supremo representar a américa
latina oa los hispanos una
puertorriqueña ahí tenemos a sonia
sotomayor báez que es la primera y se
merece un aplauso
es impresionante esto mi gente cuando a
ella la estaban dominando uno de los
periódicos más importantes de la capital
norteamericana escribió oiga la
puertorriqueña sonia sotomayor ha sido
la mejor nominada para la corte suprema
de los estados unidos en los últimos 100
años de que tuve está hablando okay
somos buenos en esas cuatro cosas que
nos habían dicho pero también somos
buenos en militar porque porque cuando
méxico se independiza acabándose
independizar forman su ejército entonces
escogen como el jefe del estado mayor el
jefe del ejército mexicano a esta
persona un militar de fajardo puerto
rico y se llama antonio valerio bernabé
vete que tú me estás diciendo que el
primer jefe del ejército mexicano fútbol
y ccoo-a de fajardo no solamente eso él
fue el que redactó el reglamento del
ejército mexicano usted cree en que
antonio valero no se merece un aplauso
bendito
somos bien buenos en esas cuatro cosas y
somos chiquititos pero por ejemplo si
nosotros vamos a centroamérica en
honduras viene que interesante en
honduras fundan un banco
hoy es el banco más importante de
honduras se llama el banco atlántida me
encuentro un hondureño que me dice mira
a mí me gusta mucho puerto rico pero
dice que puerto rico se ha destacado en
todos los países del mundo ellos en
hondura y en honduras no se destacaba
nadie ningún boricua
pues mira que le presentó a él este
señor que está aquí que aparece como
militar porque fue un prócer bien famoso
en cuba el de mayagüez ese boricua que
usted ve ahí que se llama juan rius
rivera fundó el banco más importante que
hoy opera en nombre de este rapidito que
nos vamos rapidito que nos vamos en
solidaridad tú quieres dar un ejemplo de
solidaridad más grande vaya a nicaragua
nosotros los puertorriqueños perdimos a
roberto clemente por ayudar a nicaragua
valla nicaragua mi hermano
hay avenidas calles edificios estadios
con el nombre de ese puertorriqueño
porque ellos entienden que ese gran
puertorriqueño dio su vida por nicaragua
12 medios un aplauso mire qué cuatro
cositas nada más rapidito mi gente
cuando usted visite panamá posiblemente
uno de los atractivos más grande que
panamá team es el canal de para más una
obra de ingeniería de importancia
mundial pero es importante que usted
sepa que hay un museo del canal de
panamá que no solamente te habla de la
historia del canal sino de la historia
del país es uno de los museos más
importantes y mirel hoy el museo
interoceánico de panamá lo dirige la
puertorriqueña ángeles ramos vaquero que
también se merece un aplauso mi gente
cuatro cositas nada más ustedes ahí está
en venezuela en salud en los años 1920 a
venezuela llega una puertorriqueña
casada con un venezolano ella había sido
enfermera en puerto rico y se da cuenta
que impresora no existe la enfermería
ella mueve cielo y tierra y lo logra que
logra la boricua fundar la primera
escuela de enfermería de venezuela se
llama paula santiago de sanoja y déjeme
decirle algo algo impresionante de esta
boricua es que ella fue la que buscó la
facultad y cuando todos los venezolanos
vinieron a la escuela el primer día se
encontraron que la directora y las 17
maestra todas eran puertorriqueña todas
rapidito que nos vamos astronomía
astronomía somos bueno en cuatro cosas
pero sin embargo en chile hay un
observatorio astronómico que se
consideró por mucho tiempo el más
importante de todo el hemisferio sur del
planeta se llamaba el cerro tololo y
hace unos años lo rebautizaron
hoy se llama víctor m blanco el
astrónomo puertorriqueño que lo dirigió
17 años de guayama puerto rico
rapidito gente que nos vamos que nos
vamos educación si usted ha oído hablar
en suramérica algunas montañas gigantes
que se llaman los antes hacer un tren
que cruce los andes una obra de
ingeniería y el plan estaba pero se
bloqueó y llega un educador enseñarle a
los chilenos lo argentino lo importante
que era la construcción de ese tren que
cruzará los andes cuando ese tren lo
construye y va a dar su primer viaje el
primer tren que cruzó los andes no se
llamó george washington no se abra llamó
abran lincoln no se llamó simón bolívar
el primer tren que cruzó los andes se
llamó eugenio maría de hostos pero no
solo
somos buenos cuatro cosas somos buenos
en cuatro cosas pero sin embargo en cuba
llega cuando llega la moda de que las
tienen que crecer hacia arriba cuba
construye el primer rascacielos del
caribe para que el momento en 1932 y
construyen ese edificio que usted vea
ahí que fue el primer rascacielos de
cuba 14 piso edificio lópez serrano
cuando buscamos bien es una obra de
ingeniería brutal y de arquitectura la
construyó miguel roses un arquitecto
ingeniero puertorriqueño de ponce puerto
rico rapiditos este que estamos a la
irena dominicana un país que queremos
mucho la habana y san juan tienen una
bahía santodomingo no santo domingo
tiene un río cuando los barcos empezaron
a crecer en tamaños ya no cabían y santo
domingo no tenía un puerto y le llamaba
en la ciudad sin puerto van francés e
iván estadounidense a aprobar si se
podía construir un puerto o no esa no
aquí no se puede construir un puerto
hasta que llegó un boricua ingeniero
naval y el ingeniero naval no solamente
construyó los diseñó y lo financió el
puerto de santo domingo hoy lo construyó
ese boricua félix benítez rexach
y ya nos vamos cerramos con puerto rico
en puerto rico- nosotros tenemos una
doctora que a mí me hincha el corazón
porque antes cuando dio el sida
fuertemente el problema con el sida era
que las madres que quedaban embarazadas
los niños les salían enfermo era
terrible era un dolor horrible la
puertorriqueña que usted vea y carme
vive que en puerto rico con nosotros fue
la primera científica en el mundo en
puerto rico que logró que las madres que
tuvieran h y veo sida no contagiarán a
los bebés y los primeros bebés sanos en
el planeta nacidos de mujeres infectadas
nacieron en puerto rico gracias a la
excelente labor de esta profesional
puertorriqueña gente a esos amigos en la
convención a esos amigos en la
convención le dije si somos buenos
música tropical somos buenos en belleza
somos buenos en actuación somos buenos
en eso pero también somos buenos muchas
otras cosas
muchas otras cosas somos buenos también
y así nosotros llevamos corroborando
miren en todas esas áreas que hemos
hablado hasta ahora los puertorriqueños
se destacan usted sabe lo que yo hice me
le acerqué a los dos amigos
latinoamericanos el que me hacía así
porque es a qué puerto rico era chiquito
me le acerqué le dije mi hermano espero
que esto se haya ido para enseñarte y
para que tú aprenda que la capacidad de
un país no se mide en villas cuadradas
se mide en la capacidad de su gente y mi
país en eso te puede dar y de sobra pero
una cosita más no existe no existe en el
planeta tierra un país que tenga nuestro
tamaño un país que tenga nuestra
población que más aportaciones ha hecho
a la historia de la humanidad como este
tipo de islay es mi patria y la de
ustedes si alguien se siente mal usted
hace el querer y dígale perdón el
lucimiento
es que soy puertorriqueño
[Aplausos]